en este vídeo vamos a tratar de tener un
sentido de lo que es el límite cuando
extiende a 3 de x cúbica menos 3 x
cuadrada entre 5 x menos 15 y cuando
digo tener sentido me refiero a que
vamos a hacerlo viendo qué valores
tenemos para esta expresión cuando x se
acerca más y más y más a 3 ahora una
cosa que estoy seguro que quiere
intentar es saber qué pasa con esta
expresión cuando x es igual a 3 bueno
pues vamos a ver si x es igual a 3 me
quedaría 3 elevado al cubo menos 3 por 3
al cuadrado entre 5 por 3 menos 15
entonces si x es igual a 3 esta
expresión va a ser veamos en el
numerador tenemos 27 menos 27 lo cual es
0 sobre 15 menos 15 lo cual es 0 así que
al final terminaríamos con una expresión
que no está definida next igual a 3 de
la forma indeterminada 0 sobre 0
ahora veamos que aunque la expresión no
está definida vamos a poder tener un
sentido de lo que es el límite y para
hacer eso voy a hacer una tabla por aquí
de hecho voy a hacer dos tablas entonces
en esta primera tabla
esta es la columna x y es la columna de
x copycat menos 3 x cuadrada entre 5 x
menos 15 es decir de mi función y haré
esta misma tabla de nuevo en una segunda
tabla y les diré por qué en un segundito
entonces por aquí tengo mi columna x y
por acá tengo mi función que es xq vícam
menos 3 x cuadrada entre 5 x menos 15 y
la razón por la cual posee dos tablas
podrían haber puesto dos tablas de poner
todo solamente en una pero esperemos que
esto lo haga un poquito más intuitivo
porque lo que estoy tratando de hacer es
que en la tabla de la izquierda probemos
con valores de x que se acerquen más y
más y más a 3 pero por la izquierda es
decir por valores que son menores a 3
y podremos ir con 2.9 o podríamos ir
incluso un poco más cerca que 2.9 no sé
tomarnos el valor de 2.99 e incluso
podríamos ir aún más cerca y tomar el
valor de 2.999 y entonces una manera de
plantearlo es que a medida que tratamos
de encontrar a que es igual la expresión
mientras nos acercamos más y más y más a
estamos tratando de aproximar el límite
por la izquierda deja notarlo eso es muy
importante esta tabla vamos a ver cuál
es el límite por la izquierda y por qué
digo por la izquierda bueno es que si
piensan en un plano de coordenadas estos
son los valores de x que están a la
izquierda de 3 pero nos estamos
acercando más y más y más a este valor
de 3 nos estamos moviendo hacia la
derecha pero ojo
estos valores siguen estando a la
izquierda de 3 son menores que 3 y
además para que exista el límite tenemos
que aproximarnos también por la otra
dirección tanto por la izquierda
por la derecha de ambos lados así que
también vamos a tratar de aproximar el
límite por la derecha aquí me voy a
tomar el límite por la derecha y
entonces qué valores podríamos tomar nos
bueno se me ocurren valores que sean
mayores que 3 y cercanos a 3 por ejemplo
puede tomar 3.1 pero luego tal vez
queremos estar más cerca de tres puntos
es tomo el valor de 3.01 y si queremos
estar todavía un poco más cerca que tres
podemos tomarnos el valor de 3.001 y
cada vez que vayamos más cerca y más
cerca del 3 vamos a tener una mejor
aproximación o vamos a tener un mejor
sentido de algo que en realidad nos
estamos aproximando así que vamos a
sacar una calculadora y vamos a hacer
esto y de hecho pueden seguir con 2.9 99
99 con 3.000 0001 o lo que ustedes
quieran y antes de que meta todo esto en
la calculadora quiero decir una idea
clave algunas veces cuando la gente dice
el límite por ambos lados o el límite
por la izquierda o el límite por la
derecha se imaginan que el límite
son valores negativos y el límite por la
derecha son valores positivos pero como
pueden ver aquí el límite por la
izquierda también son valores positivos
solo que estamos tomando los valores a
la izquierda del valor de x en el límite
que estamos tratando de encontrar así
que estos valores no forzosamente son
negativos sólo se están aproximando al 3
por valores menores que 3 eso lo que
significa mientras que estos otros se
están aproximando a 3 por valores
mayores a 3 entonces veamos con 2.9
queremos calcular el valor de esta
expresión y nos quedarían 2.9 esto
elevado al cubo menos 3 por 2.9 elevado
al cuadrado
me dan esto que es el numerador y si
esto lo dividimos entre 5 x
2.9 menos 15 este es nuestro denominador
ok nos va a dar igual am 1.682 ok
déjenme notarlo 1.682 ok
y ahora vamos a seguir con 2.99 2.99
esto elevado al cubo menos 3 por 2.99
elevado al cuadrado
me dan esto que es nuestro numerador y
si luego dividimos esto entre nuestro
denominador que es 5 por 2.99 menos 15
esto me da esta cantidad y bueno eso es
igual a 1.788 0 2 lo voy a dejar en
1.788 así redondeamos entonces esto es
aproximadamente 1.7 88 y ahora vamos a
aún más cerca de 3 recuerden nos estamos
aproximando a 3 por la izquierda así que
vamos a ver qué pasa con 2.999 ésta está
todavía más cerca de 3 así que de nuevo
saquemos nuestra calculadora y ahora
tenemos 2.999 esto elevado al cubo
-3 por 2.999 al cuadrado ok esto es
nuestro numerador y esto lo vamos a
dividir entre 5 por 2.999 menos 15 este
es nuestro denominador y todo esto es
igual a 1.798 8 lo voy a redondear hasta
ahí
1.798 8 que inclusive parece estar más
cercano al 1.8 se pueden comprobar si no
sé si prueban con 2.9 99 99 que se va
acercar más al 1.8 entonces esta tabla
es nuestro límite por la izquierda y
ahora vamos a probar con el límite por
la derecha a ver si nos aproximamos a
1.8 también entonces qué pasa cuando
probamos el 3.1 me quedarían 3.1 elevado
al cubo
- 3 x 3.1 elevado al cuadrado es éste
nuestro numerador ya esto lo voy a
dividir entre 5 x 3.1 menos 15
este es nuestro denominador y esto nos
da igual a 1.922 muy bien vamos a
escribirlo ok ahora vamos a hacer esto
con 3.0 13.01 elevado al cubo menos 3 x
3.01 elevado al cuadrado este es mi
numerador y esto lo voy a dividir entre
5 x 3.01 menos 15 ok y metán 1.81 de
aproximadamente 1.80 y 12 ahora sí
parece que nos estamos aproximando a 1.8
desde arriba pero vamos a acercarnos más
con 3.001 así al menos podemos terminar
lo que puse aquí
vamos a terminar nuestras tablas y vamos
a estar un poquito más seguros que sheen
vamos para allá al 1.8 inclusive si tú
quieres estar más seguro puedes probar
con no ser 3.000 0 0 0 0 1 lo que a ti
se te ocurra pero vamos a hacer por
ahorita 3.001 me quedaría 3.001 elevado
al cubo menos tres por 3.000 1 al
cuadrado este es nuestro numerador y a
esto lo voy a dividir entre 5 x 3.001
menos 15 y esto va a ser igual a 1.801
aproximadamente déjame ponerlo en 1.801
ya estamos muy muy cerca de 1.8 así que
basándonos en lo que estamos viendo aquí
haría la estimación de que esto parece
estar aproximándose a 1.8 es decir este
límite que estábamos buscando es igual a
1.8 y como he dicho en el futuro vamos a
ser capaces de encontrar esto con
exactitud
pero si no están seguros de esto podrían
probar valores aún más y más y más y más
cercanos de hecho sólo por diversión
podemos hacer un valor supere super
super cercano vamos a hacer 2.99 999 y
vamos a ver qué nos dan nos estamos
acercando por la izquierda pero ahora
estamos yendo muy muy muy muy cerca de
tres
así que si saco mi calculadora voy a
tener cuantos nueve zonas son cinco ok
59 2.999 99 elevado al cubo menos 3 por
2.99 999 elevado al cuadrado es éste
nuestro numerador dividido entre 5 por
2.99 999 menos 15 ok
este es nuestro denominador y ahora si
pongo esto igual
me dan 1.799 98 no nos estamos acercando
a 1
as a 1.8 es más si redondeamos este
valor a la milésima más cercana si
milésima más cercana voy a obtener 1.8
así que nos estamos acercando muchísimo
a 1.8 ahora si no tienen una buena
sensación sobre esto podrían ir todavía
más y más y más y más cerca de 3 para
tener una sensación más certera más
sobre este valor recuerda en una tabla
nos estamos aproximando y eso sí estamos
viendo cuál es el comportamiento a
medida que nos acercamos más y más por
la izquierda y por la derecha a 3 y esto
de hacer tablas no solamente es útil
para calcular límites a veces tendrán
que calcular cosas numéricamente de esta
manera pero en el caso de un límite al
hacerlo también les da una intuición de
lo que es un límite